hey everyone with the recent expansion
of web 3.0 the rapid growth in the
fields of artificial intelligence and
Quantum Computing and the announcement
of the implementation of ethereum merge
in 2023 the tech world is expected to
grow massively in the current economy
Tech organizations are driven by highly
skilled I.T Personnel thus offering
lucrative positions to support the
growing digital economy
organizations of false Isis are willing
to pay a hefty sum to those capable of
Bridging the rising Tech skill Empire
with their further education
certifications and work experience
hey everyone you are already watching
simply learn and here we are with the
list of the top five highest paying jobs
for the year 2023. if you love watching
videos like this do hit the Subscribe
button to never miss any updates from
Simply learning at the fifth position is
devops engineer implementing devops
frequently necessitates an
organizational redesign in organizations
where development and operations are
handled independently to properly adopt
devops you need the right people culture
and devops engineers
the goal of a devops engineer is to
balance needs through the whole software
development life cycle from coding and
deployment to maintenance and updates
skills required to acquire to become a
devops engineer include prior work
history as a 24 7 cloud or SAS operation
team member knowledge of infrastructure
management and surveillance so strong
acquaintance with devops platform tools
Chef puppet and Docker working
understanding of middleware
configuration and automation service
provisioning the ability for both
Independents and teamwork powerful
analytical abilities
now talking about the salary ranges
between 110 821 US Dollars and in India
the average salary is 7.5 lakh rupees
then at the fourth position is software
engineer
software Engineers also called software
developers design and create softwares
for computers and applications you might
find a career as a software engineer
fulfilling if you're an analytical
thinker who appreciates problem solving
and making digital things easier to use
now the skills required for a software
engineer are designing and maintaining
software systems evaluating and testing
new software programs optimizing
software for Speed and scalability
writing and testing code Consulting with
clients Engineers security Specialists
and other stakeholders now the average
salary of a software engineer in the US
is 113 775 US Dollars and in India it's
6.5 lakh rupees
and the third position is blockchain
developer according to research the
market for blockchain technology will
grow at a cagr of 85.9 percent from 2020
to 2030. it makes sense that blockchain
would be among the vocations with the
highest demand in 2023. blockchain
developers basically create systems to
collect and preserve blockchain data in
a way that hinders alterations or
hackers enabling secure digital
transactions now talking about the
skills required to become a blockchain
developer is good knowledge of
programming languages like Java Python
and C plus knowledge of algorithms data
structure and back-end development
understanding blockchain Technologies
and cryptography thorough understanding
of blockchain management best practices
and data security
and the salary of a blockchain developer
is 108 539 US Dollars and 7.5 lakh
rupees in India then at the second
position is machine learning engineer
LinkedIn claims that between 2021 and
2022 recruiting for machine learning
Engineers increased by 32 percent
the need for machine learning experts is
skyrocketing as more firms look into
using them to safeguard their operations
against upcoming challenges
and in this way machine learning
Engineers have received the second best
job in the 2023 ranking
now talking about the skills these are
the skills required to become a machine
learning engineer
statistics and probability data modeling
programming languages like python C plus
artificial intelligence algorithms
coming to the salary the average salary
of a machine learning engineer is 136
415 dollars in the US and nine lakh
rupees in India and at the topmost
position we have is data scientists to
gain a thorough picture of how a company
operates the data scientist's job
description calls for gathering
information from multiple sources and
analyzing it the data scientist creates
intelligent responses to business
difficulties by automating particular
organizational procedures using
statistical and analytical techniques
and AI tools
here are the skills required for a data
scientist making estimates for
additional analysis using statistical
techniques is made possible by
probability and technical skills like
machine learning deep learning
processing large data sets data
visualization data wrangling mathematics
and programming now talking about the
salary then the average salary of a data
scientist in the US is 121 417 dollars
and in India it's 11 lakh rupees
so with that we come to the end of this
list many other fields like cyber
security and digital marketing are short
on skilled professionals so keep looking
if any of those careers described above
or mentioned now interest you before I
sign off make sure you subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update we'll be back with more
such interesting videos until then keep
learning and stay tuned on simply learn